في هذه المناطق التي ساعدتها القوات
الاوكرانيه مؤخرا بالقرب من خاركيف يحاول
هؤلاء الاوكرانيون البحث عن القتل الذين
مزقتهم هذه الحرب ايا كان معسكرهم كانت
هناك علبه السجائر في جيبه لقد وجدنا 20
جثه
العلميه البحث عن اي علامه توصله الى
هويتها باخرى
هذه غايتهم الامل في استعاده رفت زملائهم
لوكرانيين من الجانب الاخر
بجثث زملائنا الاوكرانيين لذلك نقوم بجمع
هذه الروفات من اجل عمليه التبادل والا
فلن يسمح لنا الروس باستعاده روفه جنودنا
عملوا شاق من دون شك يتطلب الجهد والصبر
يوم الجمعه الماضي
وزوجات الجنود الذين يشاركون في عمليه
العسكريه في اوكرانيا بهدف مواساتهن
وتقديم التعازي اليهم منذ اسابيع يتزايد
الضغط على السلطات الروسيه من قبل اقارب
العائلات لا يترقون القدر الكافي عن
الظروف التي ادت الى وفاه احبائهم ما
يدخلهم في حاله حداد قد تطول كثيرا